now a 21 year old woman has died after
testing positive for covert 19 Chloe
Middleton is thought to be the youngest
person to die in the UK after testing
positive for the condition her aunt said
that she had no underlying health
conditions when a Facebook post Chloe's
mother Dan Middleton said to all the
people out there that thinks it's just a
virus please think again speaking from a
personal experience this so-called virus
has taken the life of my 21 year old
daughter let's talk to Skye's nul
Phillips no this will cause great
concern to many people weren't there
because it really has been sort of
drummed into us that it's people who are
over 17 it's people who were have
underlying conditions that are the ones
that are affected the worst and I think
that's the big concern Chloe was just 21
years old as you said her family have
taken to Facebook to release a statement
and to pay tribute to a 21 year old a
have stressed the point that she had no
underlying health conditions auntie
Emily mystery has also paid tribute to
her along with her mom Diane Middleton
who as we can only imagine right now
must be distraught must be very
distressed with losing her 21 year old
daughter but I'll just read you a quick
statement from her Auntie she said
simply my loved ones are going through
the most unimaginable pain we are
shattered beyond belief her sister Amy
is also taken to Facebook
she said my kids couldn't have had a
more loving crazy nutcase for an auntie
and we wouldn't have had it any other
way
she adored them and they certainly
adored her back now that we understand a
family who were from High Wycombe in
Buckinghamshire also urging people on
Facebook to you know follow government
guidelines and stay indoors they have
stressed that Chloe was only 21 she had
no other underlying issues and I think
it's worth stressing that as well and
and they're just for my you know wanting
to send a message to people who are not
following social distancing rules to
remember that they should take this very
very seriously and it's worth
remembering that older people are more
likely to succumb to this virus but
Chloe's death will be of some concern to
public health officials